-Our first guest tonight is
a United States senator
from the great state
of Connecticut.
Please welcome to the show
Senator Chris Murphy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you for being
with us, Senator.
-Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.
-Obviously not the easiest day,
but we really do appreciate
you making the time to try
to put the events of yesterday
in context,
if that's at all possible.
You know, one of the messages
we're trying to get across today
is it's not hopeless.
Is that one of the things
you find yourself,
as one of the leading advocates
of gun control,
do you find yourself running
up against people
who feel like it is,
in fact, hopeless?
-Of course.
In Europe at this moment,
where there are
so many Americans
who, you know, have become
so anesthetized, so numb,
to the pace
of these mass shootings.
I just can't let that happen.
I can't let people
in this country believe
that we can't change this,
because we can.
We're the only country
in the high-income world
where kids fear for their lives
when they go to school.
We have power over this.
We have agency.
And, as I'm speaking to you,
I'm literally in touch with,
you know, a half dozen or more
Republican senators
that are interested
in sitting down
and talking
about a path forward.
I don't know whether
we'll get there,
to a bipartisan product,
but I'm going to try
because, as a parent
of two school-age kids,
I just can't believe that we're
going to allow this to continue.
And I have to believe
that we can find
a handful of Republicans
in the United States Senate
that are willing to work on us
to make our schools
and our shopping malls
and our movie theaters
just a little bit safer.
-So, you were elected in 2012
and then Sandy Hook,
which was obviously
in your state, happened.
I feel like that was a moment
where people thought,
"Surely,
something will change now."
How do you reflect back on the
last decade since that happened?
-Well, that's what I
thought, too.
I mean, I thought,
if the murder of 20 kids
in an elementary school
in Connecticut
doesn't change the dynamic
on this issue, what will?
But I quickly changed my mind
because what I realized is
that this is all
about political power.
I wish it weren't, but it is.
And, in 2013,
when Sandy Hook happened,
the NRA had tons
of political power.
The gun lobby had
tons of political power,
and we had none.
There really wasn't an anti-gun
violence movement in 2013.
So we've spent the last ten
years building up our power.
We now have
all these amazing groups --
Gabby Giffords,
March for Our Lives,
and Moms Demand Action --
and the gun lobby is weaker,
you know,
they're practically bankrupt.
And so we're at this moment
where maybe, maybe, maybe,
the balance of political power
has shifted.
Maybe enough voters care
about this
that they're going
to send a message --
"If you don't vote with us,
if you don't vote with our kids,
we're voting you out of office."
But it's taken ten years
to really equalize
the political power
on the issue of guns.
Back then,
we just had none of it
and they had all of it
and that's why we lost.
-So, you were actually presiding
on the Senate floor
when this tragedy
happened yesterday
and you gave your fiery speech
that we've already referenced
tonight in the show.
What was the energy like
in the room
when you're giving that speech?
Are other senators there?
Do you feel like
they're listening?
-I mean, a lot of people
were listening.
There were only a handful
of senators there,
but I know, because I've talked
to many of them,
that a lot of them heard
what I said.
You know, I was sitting
in the Senate chamber.
I was actually presiding
over the Senate
when my phone started
to blow up
and I looked down to realize
that we had another
Sandy Hook on our hands.
And I decided to go down to the
floor immediately after
and, you know, just say simply
to my colleagues, right,
"Why on Earth did you spend
all this time running
for the United States Senate,
if you're going to do nothing?"
And I don't know
whether my colleagues
can be shamed
into doing something,
but I'm just not going
to let them off the hook.
I'm not going to let
this place do nothing
and get away without at least
some rebuke on the Senate floor.
So we'll see.
There's a lot of Republicans,
because of what I said
and because
of what their constituents
have said to them in phone calls
and emails
over the last 24 hours,
that are reaching out
to work with us
and we'll see
if we can get something done.
-It seems like Republicans
do a very good job
of framing this issue
in a fear-based way of,
"They're coming
to take away your guns."
There are many versions
of legislation
where that will not be the case.
There will be modifications,
there will be steps,
you know, closing loopholes,
things like that,
banning assault rifles.
Why do you feel like they're so
strong at framing the narrative?
And it strikes me that Democrats
have done a poorer job.
-Well, you know,
that's interesting,
that you put it that way,
because, actually,
if you look
at the polling on this,
there are very few issues
in America
in which 90% of people in this
country agree on anything
and 90% of Americans think
that you should have
universal background checks.
Actually, the majority
of Republicans
now support
an assault weapons ban.
The problem is very much just,
in this town,
Republicans,
for whatever reason,
are so afraid of the gun lobby,
the NRA,
that they can't get
out of their own way.
So I actually think we've
won this debate
in the American public.
We just need voters, now,
to do more
than sort of click
the right answer on a poll.
We need voters to say, "Hey,
in this next election,
I'm going to ask
the candidates,
'Do you support banning
assault weapons?
Do you support universal
background checks?'
and not vote for the folks
that give the wrong answer."
-You talk about the fact
that you've won on the issue,
but you've also been critical
of Democrats
not wanting to run on it.
Don't you feel like there is --
If the GOP's afraid
of the gun lobby,
it strikes me that the Democrats
are afraid of something
because they don't run on it
in a way that --
certainly not as strongly
as you lay it out.
-Yeah, we're sort of stuck
in a world that doesn't exist.
Democrats think
that we will lose votes
if we talk about gun violence,
and that's just not true.
In fact, in 2018,
record numbers of young people
turned out in that election.
Democrats won control of the
House of Representatives. Why?
Because we talked about the
issue of gun violence.
So, the NRA has kind of created
this mythology
that running on things
like background checks
is a losing political issue.
It's the exact opposite.
It actually convinces
a lot of people
who weren't planning
on turning out to turn out,
and it's a lot of swing voters
who want to hear Democrats,
want to hear candidates,
talk about
the most pressing moral issue
that they and their kids face,
which, right now, is the fear
that our kids have
for their lives
when they walk into schools.
We have to talk about this
and we'll win votes
if we talk about it.
-Sometimes I think there's
a frustration at a distance --
maybe people don't understand
quite how it works in D.C. --
at the speed
in which things happen.
It always strikes me as a little
bit slower than it should,
especially after a tragedy
like this.
When do you see,
when you predict,
any vote coming to the floor
that would actually
force Republicans
to choose a side to land on?
-Well, the other thing
to sort of note here is
that the reason
why it's taking so long is
because of the rules
in the Senate, right?
You've got this rule that says
50 votes isn't good enough.
You need 60 votes.
So the voters kind of
did their job.
They elected a majority
in the Senate,
a majority in the House,
and a president who all support
something like
universal background checks.
The problem is we have 50 votes
in the Senate, not 60 votes.
So, you know, part of what
has to happen here is
that we change the rules
of the Senate so that,
if the voters put majorities
in charge of everything,
then they actually get
what they are asking for.
And, in this case,
they're asking
for universal background checks
and they're only not getting it
because we've got this silly
sort of
19-, you know, -50s-era rule
in the Senate
that requires 60 votes.
-Obviously, from your time
visiting, speaking with people
in the community of Sandy Hook,
you are acutely aware that maybe
the rest of us move on,
but communities where something
like this happen never do.
-Never do.
Never do.
Sandy Hook will never,
ever be the same.
Because the research tells us,
for every individual
that's killed,
there are 20 people
who know them,
20 relatives and friends
who experience trauma.
You know,
I tell the story in Newtown.
I told it on the floor
just last night.
You know, afterwards, when those
kids came back to that school,
they had to have
this procedure in place that,
when a kid had a memory
of what he saw that day,
you know,
stepping over his dead bodies --
his classmates' dead bodies,
they would scream out
a safe word
and that paraprofessionals
and psychologists
and psychiatrists would come
and help them.
In one classroom,
that word was monkey.
And so all throughout the day,
kids would be screaming out,
"Monkey! Monkey!"
And paraprofessionals
would come and help them.
That's just a sign
of how devastating this is,
how the pain never goes away
in a place like Newtown.
It's never going to go away
in Uvalde.
And we just have
a moral obligation,
as a nation,
to try to make sure
that this doesn't happen
to another community
because you don't recover
from this.
As a family, you don't recover
and, as a community,
you don't recover.
So why on Earth do we allow
for communities
to still go through this?
-I'd love -- I would really love
and appreciate
if you could leave us
with any path forward,
any reason for optimism,
anything those of us watching
who believe that there is some
step of gun control we can take,
what we can be doing.
-Well, I just want to make sure
people know
lots of things have changed
since Sandy Hook.
In fact, there have been dozens
of states that have passed laws
that have tightened gun laws
and have saved lives.
The NRA is weaker
than they were in 2013.
The gun violence movement
is stronger.
When Republicans had control
of the entire Congress,
the NRA got nothing
from the Republican Congress.
They used to get everything
when Republicans were in charge.
Why?
Because Republicans maybe aren't
willing, yet, to vote with us,
but they're not willing
any longer to vote with the NRA.
I know that people want this all
to happen overnight,
but it took ten years
from when James Brady was shot
during the assassination attempt
to President Reagan
until the James Brady background
check law was passed.
It took over ten years
from the open casket
of Emmett Till
until the Civil Rights Act
was passed.
Sometimes, in this country,
it does take a decade or more
to get great
social change passed.
And we have made
a lot of progress,
more progress than people think
and, boy,
there's no more important issue
to continue to stay active on.
Don't let obstacles stand
in the way of your advocacy.
We will get this done,
in the end.
-Senator,
I cannot thank you enough
for giving us your time today.
Keep up the good fight
and we really appreciate it.
-Thanks, Seth.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Senator Chris Murphy,
everybody. We'll be right back.